guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters in
charlotte help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their
[Music]
break the fast you're finished you're
finished you're finished
why are you finished yeah okay sure i
don't think what the [ __ ]
what the flipper whoa whoa for what whoa
what what
family should you just say bismillah
before she drank alco
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah this is
a message to sq and musa do you like
my new swagger if you do please rate it
from 1 to 10 on the comment section
we're going to come to a very straight
video i'm going to get straight to the
point before that brother and sisters we
are trying to get
three hundred thousand meals inshallah
three hundred thousand meals go to the
link in the description box not a long
thing it's a chunk thing yes promises
i'll be telling you why i'm just not
in a minute is to get your attention
actually it's a bit clickbait i'm doing
different clickbaits
this is let's get straight into this one
that's what you thought okay you'll be
quiet boy you're finished you're
finished you're finished
why are you finished okay brother and
sisters in china yeah the jokes aside
okay
now let's react to this video yeah uh
alhamdulillah um brother zeeshan and
since islam did a beautiful video as
well in different perspectives but i'm
coming from a different angle
let's watch this yeah and let's see what
this is about but the main purpose of
the video about them
is to i'm doing this video i didn't
really want to do it because brother
muhammad smith's adrenaline and other
channels covered it but i'm doing this
because my main aim is to raise funds
for the meals problems so that's why i'm
doing the video
so if you have entertainment inshallah
and uh we can learn something and do
something good sadhaka
and this video should help you do
sadhaka and here's why let's watch this
break the fast break the fast
they annoy me or lie they annoy me break
they're fast that's a cricket anyways
let's carry them
[Music]
you know after accountant i would love
to do something um
to that guy right yeah fast guy but
anyways
it's wrong my dad let's carry on
fam did you just say bismillah before
she drank let me rewind that for a
second
bismillah sorry about the music guys
[Music]
wow wow i mean guys there's a very short
clip yeah
um let me tell you guys and get straight
to the point okay let me tell my
glossary
okay brothers and sisters yeah let me
tell you
something i have lived that lifestyle
i've been to clubs
i've you know partying holidays you name
it okay
i've been there in these night clubs i
would see
girls drinking half drunk being as
they're walking past
they've been touched up by men like his
happy days yeah
but they've been touched up like she's
some kind of a holy thing brother like
you just you know you want to get some
blessings from it
humiliated drunk vomiting crying
depressed
the only reason people love fridays and
hate mondays is because
it's one moment the weekend where you
can get away with your problems by
drinking
and they are trying to popularize that
one wow bismillah whoa yes
yeah shame on you you know shame on you
guys netflix
yeah and you know what this shows with
provinces they know islam is the truth
they know they know it is from allah
and they are trying their best to
popularize this men like drink alcohol
wow what a life look at me drunk yeah
drunk and most of these people end up
being alcoholics
yeah recent studies show even a little
drinking alcohol they even say
it's still not good for you recent
studies show that drinking alcohol
it causes for you to become an alcoholic
eventually yeah
subhanallah brothers and sisters you
guys in this month of ramadan you should
be more adamant
pray in your salah fasting given in
zakah giving in sadaqah
getting closer to your religion brother
sisters because these people
they've got do you know what that shows
that shows to me desperation they're
saying we're losing the battle
because the youth the people are turning
to islam in the west in the western
world
people like myself hamza zoltan abdul
rahim green
yusuf s says so many people are coming
to islam why because they know it's the
truth
why because they know that void in their
heart they know that void in their heart
and islam is the only way that you would
have
peace in your heart because allah says
indeed with the remembrance of allah do
hearts find peace that's why they're
trying to polarize this idea with you
like
oh it's so fun and you get caught up
because you're insecure
you're insecure and beneath yourself and
i'll end this though i don't want to
make this video quite long
bani israel did the same thing when
muslim with the permission of allah
allah saved them from egypt from
firaoun's
they came out and imagined muslims come
back and they worship in the
calf the calf they're worshiping the cow
golden cow why would they do that think
for a second god has just saving them
from who's killing their children or
pressing them they come out these lands
and they go back to shirk
let me tell you why because they are
insecure
they were looking around other people
having uh statues and idols
they were it's insecurity oh they have
that
that must be right let's do the same the
exact same thing you see in this video
insecurity
you know oh i want to be cool like the
others drinking alcohol yeah let's shut
her oh
what the flipping is they always do that
i never understood people around the
table
i've been hungry i've never done alcohol
but i would be around circles where i
feel like yeah we'll get sure
whoa what the [ __ ] whoa what the flipper
for what whoa what
what yeah you're gonna be drunk halfway
walking down the road somebody's going
to come and take advantage of you
murder you drunk alcohol is the mother
of
all evils alhamdulillah for islam islam
is here
for prevention rather than cure so
brother sisters that's it i don't want
to talk anymore inshallah i want you
guys
inshallah peace for the sake of
subhanallah to help me reach that target
shuttle of 300 000 meals may allah
purify intentions allow us to be a means
for people to benefit inshallah brothers
and sisters hope you enjoyed this
enjoy this video don't forget to check
this out video as well and since islam
not a long thing it's a chunk thing let
me end with that style
are you guys ready
it's a bum thing
keep strong with your deen